if you look in the modern world for
example and you try to predict number of
available sexual partners for a given
male your best
predictive measure of that is
income
and the best predictive measure of that
is intelligence and conscientiousness
and so
what happens is that males orient
themselves in groups
and then they compete
and then women peel off the top
and so and so the women are in a
position of judgment on men and the
judgment is the judgment of nature but
from a darwinian perspective you can
define nature much more
straightforwardly and more accurately as
that which selects now you know you hear
a lot about natural selection and
natural selection basically assumes that
there are a random distribution of
alterations
in genetic structure in any population
in any generation and some of those
random alterations will be more suited
to that particular environment suited
being they'll live
and they'll reproduce
and
genetic transformation takes place
across the millennia as the organism
chases the landscape roughly speaking
but darwin you know darwin who is an
unbelievably intelligent person was also
very very interested in sexual selection
and as far as darwin was concerned
sexual selection was just as powerful a
force in modifying
genetic structure modifying and driving
evolution as
um
natural selection so you think do you
have any choice do you make any choice
in who your partner will be a sexual
partner will be
and the answer to that is well it's
hardly random you make a choice and
what's interesting is that you know if
you take 60 people let's say if you took
60 women and you asked them you showed
them a bunch of men and you asked them
to rank them in terms of their
attractiveness there's going to be
fairly consistent rankings you know i
mean we know
what makes up attractive facial features
for women and for men it's easy to
determine that what you do is you take
60 faces and you you average the
features so you don't get the average
person because the average person is
more like a median you get the averaged
person and the average person has
perfectly symmetrical features that are
nicely shaped and fairly big guys and
and and they're they're very you know
they're very nice looking they're very
attractive and so that means that
there's like a central human form in a
sense that we're
we find attractive and we see this in
other species for example there are
butterflies who won't mate with another
butterfly if it's if it's like a 16th of
an inch out of symmetry because then
it's not a butterfly of that type you
know and that's how people think too is
the more you deviate from the averaged
person the less canonically human you
appear and the less attractive that you
appear and then you know there are
certain physical characteristics um wide
shoulders in men and narrow waist in
women it's waist to hip ratio is a very
common marker of beauty
well you can certainly claim that the
ideal male
is represented in mythology as a hero
so and that's actually what mythology is
about it's about representing ideal
patterns of behavior so it's hardly
surprising so you know if you go to a
movie and it's a romance and there's the
main lead character that you're supposed
to fall in love with if you happen to be
the kind of person that would fall in
love with that kind of person then he's
going to act out a partic a particular
pattern of behavior and the pattern of
behavior is quite identifiable so for
example he's going to be he's going to
move forward and explore and not hide in
power and the probability that he's
going to be creative is very high and
the probability that he's going to be
good looking and strong is very high
self-evident ones
but you know people are also evaluating
each other for such things as
intelligence and personality and
character and you could say in some
sense the men are competing to be the
best man and the women are watching the
male competition to to take the man who
wins on the presupposition that he
wouldn't win if he wasn't the best man
you could say that the male dominance
hierarchy is equivalent to the stock
market it's exactly equivalent to the
stock market is the like the stocks are
stocks are always competing with one
another and with every other commodity
for
primacy of price and value and that's
exactly what happens with male
competition